hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
it's undoubtedly very well known at this
point that there is a problem with gun
violence in the united states especially
compared to other countries people
debate how best to measure this but
compared to the countries that the us
would generally consider its peers that
is to say other developed wealthy
purportedly well-functioning societies
the united states has a lot more gun
violence per capita than any of our
comparison nations now i feel a little
bit weird because we're going to be
talking today about gun violence but not
about the kind of mass shootings that
have been in the news recently as i'm
recording this intro recently there was
a mass shooting in uvalde texas there
have been others really terrible events
where someone is able to get a weapon
that fires a lot of ammunition very very
quickly break into a school or other
kind of place where there's a lot of
people and do an enormous amount of
damage this is clearly a problem we're
not talking about what that one today
there are other problems out there so
today we're talking to andrew papa
christos andrew is a sociologist at
northwestern university just outside
chicago and what he's doing is using
ideas from network theory something that
we talked about before with people like
steven strogatz andrew uses network
theory to predict what kinds of people
and specifically which people might be
vulnerable to imminent gun violence but
not in the mass shooting sense more like
the gangs on the street
crews
that get into flare-ups where they start
firing at each other kind of violence
it's an interesting problem that sort of
combines criminology sociology and math
because you use the math of the network
theory to say well this person is in the
following network in the following ways
with the these other people that puts
them at greater risk than they might
otherwise be for better for worse we
have a lot of data out there on people
on who they talk to who they know who
they've been in prison with who they've
been in a gang with things like that and
the good news is that we can use that
data to say okay this specific set of
people might be at greater risk right
now because there's recently been
another shooting now you can go in and
try to protect the people who are more
at risk than others uh it's not in any
sense a panacea a be-all end-all way to
end gun violence but we have so much
here in the united states that it is a
strategy that might be helpful when
we're trying to deploy the resources we
have in the most effective ways
i'm not personally enough of an expert
to say whether or not this is a the
right way to go or you know the best way
to use our resources but it certainly is
an interesting combination of
mathematical analysis you know big data
kind of analysis of sociological
phenomena and real world applications
that might help us to maybe save a few
lives here or there if we could do that
that would be well worth the effort so
let's go
[Music]
andrew papa christos welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you it's a
pleasure to be here gun violence is what
you work on as a professional uh
pastime you know whenever i whenever i
get people on the podcast who work on
these slightly touchy subjects
i'm kind of curious because i work on
physics and cosmology and philosophy in
the beginning of the universe and even
those are touchy subjects like people
get very emotional about them but you
work on gun violence which i imagine
must uh engender some reactions from
people who hear about your work in the
media
it definitely does i mean gun violence
is is not unique to america but there is
a uniquely american
take on gun violence and what americans
think about guns and how we use guns in
our history with guns and the number of
guns we have
and so you know i think a lot of of what
i try to do is understand the science
behind gun violence
and there are of course interventions
and preventions and policy measures that
can reduce
or make things worse but by and large
what i try to do is i try to approach it
as a social scientist to figure out how
we can understand these patterns that we
see especially in cities and especially
when people are harming each other as
opposed to suicide which is the most
common form of lethal gun violence in
this country which is quite different
so i try to look at assault of gun
violence when people use firearms to
kill other people
and i try to really kind of unpack those
patterns that we see not just aggregate
statistics so that we can hopefully do
something about that problem and and the
situations that create them
and the the currents that are both big
and small that keep these levels of gun
violence unacceptably and stubbornly
high in some places rather than other
places well you mentioned already the
fact that there is something uniquely
american about this uh can we let's try
to quantify that because i think a lot
of us recognize that america is an
outlier when it comes to gun violence in
various ways so is that
are we right about that and how much is
it and why is that true simple questions
simple questions so clearly uh you know
the united states is not unique
relative to say
other
european countries when it comes to
things like robbery
or
non-gun assaults we are unique when it
comes to our gun homicide and gun
assault levels of violence which are you
know tens of times higher than some of
our other peers or who we consider to be
our peers part of this of course is the
presence of firearms we have more guns
in this country than people which is not
to say those guns are evenly distributed
across households they are not right
most people that own a gun owned
multiple guns which is again not
uncommon of people that are into
something right some people are into
shoes and sneakers and cars and some
people are into guns for whatever reason
so there's a unique there's unique part
of this country that is about you know
owning a gun it is it is a
constitutional right
and is being upheld by the supreme court
there's also something uniquely american
about the idea of arming ourselves to
protect ourselves so the number one
reason people
carry or own a firearm in this country
is for protection
uh and then sort of the tricky science
part is actually owning and carrying
guns actually makes you less safe
so despite that this idea that guns will
keep us safe is pervasive and it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter whether you
live in the suburbs doesn't matter
whether you live in a a neighborhood
that is experiencing a disproportionate
amount of gun violence the reason people
carry guns is for protection there's
also an element in this country which
you know this last surge in gun
purchasing during the epidemic
people also arm themselves when they
feel like they have to take care of
themselves outside of the confines of
the state either the state has let them
down the state's not protecting their
interests or the state is actively
harming them which is also goes back to
the founding of this country and as it
doesn't just apply to one particular
group or the other um you know the black
panthers aren't themselves for that very
reason uh and we're seeing you know
militias arming themselves for that race
very reason and private citizens
purchase guns because they feel like
they might have to protect their their
own selves because they can't rely on
somebody to come when they call so i
think this is implicit in what you just
said but it's not
just a matter of having more guns
if i recall correctly canadians have
more guns per capita than americans do
but the culture is very different you're
really putting your finger on the way
that we think about guns and why we own
them i think that's right i also think
it's fair to say that there there are
guns that are
the ones we associate with violence
interpersonal violence which are
handguns uh which are handguns that are
often diverted
from legal sources to illegal sources so
you know they are bought they're stolen
they're traded they're stock straw
purchasers this idea of a
gun show loophole is not actually about
gun shows as much as the lack of
regulation for private transactions
which is in most states in this country
i can sell you a gun
without telling anybody right yeah there
are certain rules that i am supposed to
uphold
you have to be of age i have to
reasonably believe you wouldn't fail a
background check but i don't have to do
a background check if i'm a private
citizen
just selling a gun like i'm selling a
private car to somebody
um so there are guns that are the ones
that are problem and there are those
guns they're not all guns
largely handguns that are acquired
illegally or that have somehow been
diverted
from these sorts of sources
which is also unique because they're
durable right guns are by and large
durable goods
they're not like say drugs or you know
some other food whether you you eat them
you ingest them they're gone you get
more guns stay around for a long time
and so they get they get they get they
move around
you mentioned that suicides are actually
the largest form largest way that guns
uh kill people in the u.s i mean give us
a sense of the numbers not just of
suicides versus homicides but also of
what kinds of homicides we're talking
about because i know that when you study
uh gun homicides in cities that's sort
of a very different kind of thing that
might happen uh in rural areas or
suburbs or whatever
right i i don't have the the suicide
figures
uh in front of me
when we're there but by and large
you know i'm i'm pretty sure
you know where there's like almost five
to one
suicides for every gun homicide in this
country but yeah sorry sorry to put you
on the spot i didn't need to be no no
okay i just i don't study suicide so
oftentimes it kind of uh it it's i
neglect it as well we talk about it in
class but it's it's not something i
spend a lot of time on but the point is
it's not ten percent more than homicides
it's
at least
several times yeah absolutely absolutely
when we're talking about uh assaultive
violence where you fire a gun at
somebody and they get hit
or they get hit and die and i should say
we know very little about non-fatal
shootings because data is very poor and
even in cities like chicago they're five
or six to one non-fatal shootings for
every fatal shooting so you have
literally tens of thousands of people
who are injured with firearms that we
know very little about
when it comes to homicides which we have
better data on not perfect data you know
there are different types and and you
know it's important to distinguish at
least three of these types
um one one is of course our course mass
shootings spree shootings the kinds we
see that are going around the country
again right now and
uh you know as we're seeing in shopping
malls and schools
um and theirs are quite distinct from
other two real types one is intimate
partner violence okay which is again
extremely serious but but a very
different sort than the third
which is the lion's share of gun
homicides which is essentially assault
assaults right people that know each
other arguments disputes and that's
commonly that's kind of what shows up on
the front page more often than not and
part of the reason it gets more
attention besides it's the the large
volume the largest volume of gun
homicides is often times it's public
right intimate partner violence happens
behind closed doors so we often don't
hear about it we don't know a lot about
it it's expressing problem which needs
attention as are mass shootings but the
everyday sort of assault of violence is
the stuff that
um we often talk about so stuff i focus
on it's also the stuff that creates
additional trauma in communities you're
exposed to it somebody's shot on your
block it impacts you it impacts your
kids it impacts the school it impacts
the police
those are the sorts of um
work that the violence that we look at
so you said you seem to say when
mentioning assault of violence
against people who you know or you know
rival gang or something like that is
does that category also include if
someone robs a bank and it goes terribly
wrong and they kill somebody
yeah i would it would actually include
them and that happens much more rarely
than before of course um you know there
could be even a third cat a fourth
category of of state violence especially
those uh shot by police and then again
of course you branch off into was it the
commission of a crime you know was it a
traffic stop was it a mistaken identity
was it intentional
um but in that case again those are
smaller portions of the total the
majority of gun homicides are these
assaultive interactions essentially so i
mean so that already tells us something
that uh when there is going to be an
assault of homicide uh or rather let's
just broaden it when someone is killed
with a gun by another person it sounds
like
usually if it's not a mass shooting it's
by someone who they know or have some
connection with in some more abstract
way
that's right i mean so this idea of
stranger homicide is is actually quite
rare two-thirds that we know of
are by people that are known to the
person who was injured or killed
and the other third we actually just
don't know it's not that that other
third was strangers so we just don't
know who did it right uh and by the way
your enemy is often not a stranger the
person who you got into a fight with is
often not a stranger
neighborhood from your class from work
from the pub
um they're they're not unknown you know
them you just might not like them which
is different than than stranger because
it you know when we read about this in
the media of course the fear that is
stoked is that it it could happen to
anybody it could happen anywhere there
are stray bullet killings that are you
know accidentally kill somebody but that
that is again not the norm most of this
violence is happening in
um social networks in small communities
that people are known to each other
and you know i think it's important that
we understand that they're all tragic
but they're not random of course and i
think that helps us understand solutions
as well i mean just to get on the table
the idea you know i think that exactly
because this is such a hot button issue
and such an emotional issue some people
will be upset when you talk about
certain types of gun violence and not
others right or you're choosing to focus
on something and uh i'll just go on the
record of saying that i would like to
understand it all so that we can
diminish the rate of all of it no matter
what kind of gun violence it is
yeah yeah
i think that's fair i think the the only
reason it's important to unpack it is
the
the treatment if you will or the
response is not necessarily the same
exactly um
you know and i do think it's important
because we often talk about gun violence
as an epidemic or public health problem
which it is if we take that literally
though we do need to understand
understand whether hey it was intimate
partner violence versus a mass shooting
is going to elicit a different response
right it's it's very hard to predict
in any real sense mass shootings you can
look for warning signs there are things
like red flag laws which are when you
prohibit somebody from owning a firearm
that can reduce intimate partner
violence and mass shootings
but then there are other things that
that would necessarily apply to say you
know a young man on chicago's west side
who's involved with the dispute in a
crew right they're not using legal
firearms no flag would go off they're
probably outside of say a school system
or a health system where a red flag
would pop up
so the response you know needs to fit
the the sort of conditions at least in
at least in some sense so just to ground
us with some uh specifics one of the
papers that i saw of yours i think that
you sent me uh was about the very short
period of time between june 18 and july
5 2020
so not long after lockdowns had begun
with covet and so forth but there was a
real
spur to violence uh in chicago so you're
you're in chicago right you're at
where where are you at sorry
northwestern northwestern you're not
really in chicago yeah
you're in the suburbs but you're right
there i used to live in chicago in you
know
lakeview so
again not that much risk of gun violence
in my neighborhood although there's a
lot of risk of like drunken people
coming out of wrigley field and swinging
baseball bats but that's a different
worry
so you're looking at
shootings and very localized in
neighborhoods relatively in chicago and
so if i if i have the numbers right from
that paper you wrote in that
two or three week period there were 416
shootings 74 of which were fatal so
what do we know about why that happened
uh was it just stir craziness from covid
was it pre-existing conditions that just
coincidentally erupted or what
well i think if i had the answer to the
why it went up question uh i would be on
the front page of every paper i think
academics and criminologists have lots
of theories about why it went up um and
there are there are many of them one of
which is yeah people's routine
activities changed and they changed in a
way that
that led to increases in gun violence
but decreases and other sorts of
violence so it's hard to break in your
house if you're home
but if you're sitting at home looking at
something at social media and you're you
know your your opposition
is taunting you well you know right
where they are and you don't have any
place else to go so
you know it changed the way people could
respond intimate partner violence would
also go up if you're at home with your
abuser and can't get out so there are
lots of reasons it's hard to say which
one it does it's also seems to be clear
that people started carrying more guns
um during this time period because they
were afraid because a lot of things were
happening but
that report you mentioned point out the
work my team and i have been doing for
the past decade which is when it comes
to gun violence in cities
and here we've studied chicago and
boston and oakland and new york and
newark and cincinnati and new orleans
and even evanston which is where
northwestern
lives and we've noticed a pattern that
is consistent which is gun violence
concentrates in very very small social
networks
even in communities that have high
levels of gun violence or experience
high levels of gun violence
generally the victims and potential
perpetrators of shootings
are in a network of a couple hundred
people right or depending on the city or
neighborhood a couple thousand people so
in our study of boston 85 of all fatal
and non-fatal shootings
happened in a network of 700 people less
than four percent of this community's
population and in chicago and we did the
whole city of chicago again less than
four percent about 75 percent
of the fatal and non-fatal shootings and
when i'm talking about networks here i'm
talking about instances where people
were either engaging in a crime together
or rested together or were co-involved
in an event that elicits some system
response but we can think of it broadly
as the people you hang out with yeah the
people that hang out with that would
have your back in a fight
are tend to be your network and it turns
out what we found in chicago in general
but during this three-week period
was that your probability of being a
victim is directly related to how many
people around you are getting shot so if
your friends if you're in parts of a
network where victimizations are
happening your probability skyrockets
and in fact these can create cascades so
one person gets shot and then a few days
later somebody else or months later
somebody else it's almost like a chain a
chain reaction if you will
and what we found during those three
week period was
all of these old well-worn pathways
these old networks that had been in the
neighborhood sometimes active sometimes
unactive uh started popping up so again
not in new places or unexpected places
but among
groups and individuals and crews who
were already at high level at risk all
of a sudden the sort of the light
started going off and shooting started
to happen and in one of these chains for
instance there was four shootings in 10
days and another one there was six
shootings within 15 or 16 days right but
again sequence that was was knowable and
predictable potentially and you know
part of what we were arguing in
continuing argument is that's the sort
of information
that can be actionable for on-the-ground
violence prevention efforts to try to
get ahead of
not just shootings but trauma
and and responses to people who might be
victimized so the idea is that obviously
like different sets of people have
different likelihoods of being in one of
these terrible shootings depending on
your income your geographical location
your race your age and things like that
but you're saying there's sort of even
more fine-grained data about who your
friends are that could be used to really
say no you in particular are at
heightened risk
right so the first way you sort of
described it are you are usually what we
call the sort of risk factors approach
and to summarize you know a century of
research uh you know living in a poor
neighborhood being young being black or
latino being male
all of those things carry high levels of
risk in this country for a great many
things from heart disease
to you know dropping out of school but
especially to gun homicide to being a
victim of gun homicides one of the
leading causes of death for young black
men in this country and young black
women
latinos of course have higher rates than
than their white peers but by and large
this is one of the main killers of young
men of color
so but but when you start to look in a
city like chicago and say you're going
to again say the west side of chicago
well those risk factors describe 90 000
people yeah
and um i'm saying i'm using air quotes
here for the radio only a few hundred
will get shot so so it's not
being poor
you know or or being in a neighborhood
that has been
disinvested in and segregated for
centuries right that's part of it but
most people that live there
don't get shot or don't shoot anybody so
how do you go from these structural
conditions which are real which create
these networks
to trying to figure out who's in harm's
way today and that's the jump we take
right you want to create small networks
with a lot of guns in them you have a
segregated neighborhood with high-rise
housing projects and you close schools
right but that condition is there and
when it needs attention and in the
meantime you have to save lives and sort
of this network focus is really uh it's
more triage than it is changing
structural conditions
um but you need to do both of course but
it isn't it is a piece of information
instead of analytics that can be used to
potentially again mitigate trauma and
maybe reduce reduce harm while you're
trying to figure out the big stuff but
the end result is not a vague
description of risk factors it is
potentially
you know some estimates of like yeah
sean's in harm's way or andy's friends
are getting shot maybe we should reach
out to andy
and that that it becomes actionable for
again for for on the ground prevention
efforts so was this particular jump in
uh june july 2020
a chicago phenomenon or did it happen in
other places as well in the us
so
it happened in most it happened across
the u.s chicago is definitely not unique
nor was chicago the the highest increase
i mean some of the some of the highest
increases happened in cities we're not
talking about buffalo you know flint
newark um chicago did horribly let's
just clear but it affected the whole
country a country as a whole chicago
probably had the highest number which we
continue to do but we're not usually the
highest per capita and chicago had a
horrible 2021.
things are looking a little bit better
so far this year in chicago but it's way
too early to to know what's going to
happen i mean this might be jumping
ahead but is there some
sociological theoretical explanation of
why
chicago in particular is very bad when
you say like buffalo flint i can see
economic
issues that are looming very large
chicago seems to be economically to be
doing pretty well at least it was when i
lived there obviously it has a
tremendous history of segregation
and racial issues but
other cities do too new york la whatever
uh i mean or there might just be kind of
special
circumstances that we can't explain with
some grand sociological theory well
first of all chicago is special let's
just be clear it's the greatest greatest
city in the world um however you know to
answer your question chicago
i would say today the best comparison
would be los angeles in the 1990s
you know some of the things that keep
chicago's homicide rate higher than its
peers and it often gets kids compared to
chica and new york and la
has to do with with the levels and the
size of the city what keeps chicago
unique one of the things outside of
segregation
racist housing policies and all the
things that
kind of create neighborhoods that have
high crime rates and keep that in that
way is its history of gangs in this city
which is um fundamentally different than
some of those other cities la had a
similar history as did new york
but their gangs didn't um
grow as big and as pervasive as
chicago's in terms of the level of
organization and politics
politicalization
and that still lingers to this day
um
guns chicago recovers more guns there
are more guns in chicago than there are
in new york or l.a and part of that is
not necessarily the city's gun laws or
the states but our proximity to states
like indiana
um which is where our second largest
source of guns come from which is
largely a cash and carry state
and the two other ones which are really
important and there are others one is
you know the continued dominance of a
political machine system which is slowly
changed over time
but you know that's part of what keeps
crime in some neighborhoods and not in
other neighborhoods it creates the
boundaries you know almost
criminological gerrymandering um you
know in a sense where i'm going to
actually write that one down
but
it's it's pretty much what you have like
if you're a a powerful ward
uh boss you can get services cops will
come you know they will do sweeps and
serve warrants
and the last thing which is so important
in chicago
is of course the utter lack of i'm using
the word reform um broadly but like
change in policing in this city
so i point to la because la had similar
gangs to chicago in the 90s horrific
scandals in policing the rampart scandal
was one of the worst in the history of
this country it's no longer the worst
chicago is beating it with the new
watts scandal
but it was one of the worst and they had
a consent decree and they had massive
shake-up of that department now i'm not
saying that's the solution because the
same time la did that they also started
their grid office which was their public
office for gun violence reduction
chicago just started that office two
years ago okay so we haven't seen their
reforms for the justice system we
haven't seen investment and
on-the-ground community violence
prevention and sort of our gangs and our
politics were stuck you know essentially
decades behind so i think those are some
of the key key reasons that kind of keep
our homicide levels higher and i
actually think we need to address
all of those you know starting from
systemic racism you know all the way up
to investments in community uh uh
violence invention efforts to to see
real change in in chicago but maybe the
optimistic way of reading what you just
said is that police reform and changing
in police practices or or neighborhood i
don't know outreach practices etc could
potentially have a really big positive
impact
i think they can't i think the key is
you have to do them all at once
so you know i think going back to the
networks we study like yeah you can stop
bleeding in networks
but the network is huge and it's going
to win so unless you do something to
mitigate say people's entrance into the
network or you know you know dissipate
say segregation that can can do those
sorts of things you're just gonna you
know you're just gonna try to stop the
water from coming through the dam in
some ways so for example when you look
at you know trying to change policing
efforts and investment in community
based violence prevention efforts you
know chicago's
again i don't have the numbers in front
of me but it's the largest single
investment in community violence
intervention in the city's history you
know upwards of 36 million dollars
as a police budget of 2 billion right
and we have we have 5 000 excuse me we
have 12 000 police officers and you have
200 street outreach workers in the city
so you know um you're trying to build a
profession of say street outreach
with
good investment for the first time ever
but it's not on par with what it even
needs to be close to being so
you know i think you have to kind of get
those things and i did mention in la
they both had some serious efforts at
changing the structure of policing as
they were also increasing investments in
community violence prevention and they
were doing those things at the same time
and if you look at los angeles today in
their grid office you know they have
officers that are assigned to these
community
places
is it is the relationship always great
no
um but there is information sharing
there is a there are you know
accountability mechanisms in place and
there are just some things that we need
to figure out um that we're just
starting i actually do think that the
starting of the office or excuse me the
expansion of the office for for violence
prevention in chicago is great the state
of illinois
also just created its own office for
violence prevention that is hugely
important uh turns out there are other
cities in in illinois um and some of
them
some of them need a lot of help and they
haven't been getting attention because
of you know the dominance of chicago in
the public narrative i want to ask more
about the gangs because clearly they
play an important role and i suspect
that the typical person's view of gangs
and how they work etc doesn't perfectly
match up with the reality of it
especially since you said how chicago
was especially
uh a prevalent case whereas since i i
lived in both chicago and l.a if you ask
me i would have said la is the is the
gang city much more than chicago is that
just because i'm out of date uh yeah
it's just you haven't realized chicago's
you know uh
specialness enough essentially so
you know it i i don't know enough about
la in terms of its neighborhood
factors i would assume it's more similar
than dis similar to chicago but um
you know today street gangs in chicago
crews clicks they're much smaller than
they were in their heyday of the 90s
um they're very neighborhood based there
are there are some groups that are still
more organized and involved in sort of
you know high level back to criminal
activities but very few i mean there are
by some estimates 900 small clicks and
crews in the city of chicago and most of
them
again are bound to a particular
neighborhood couple blocks uh that out
they have been their history goes back
years and years and years and decades
but they um you know the dynamics change
quickly a lot of it has to do with in
chicago it's tied to again old disputes
new disputes things that might flare up
online and could lead to offline
violence which happens but not as often
as the media would have you think
um
but they're small you know they're small
crews that are really tied to a
neighborhood and they're friends and
that that part is not as different than
groups in other
cities it's this long legacy right the
the length with which people can trace
back
their ties to such and such a group goes
back generations
and it has meaning gives meaning to life
sometimes it's a voice of resistance
sometimes it's a voice of protection
and you know that's one of the things
that happens you know as a real simple
example
when you ask people how they find their
guns
the idea of a gang the fundamental
reason people join gangs
is for protection which is the same
reason people buy guns
and who in chicago are more likely to
have guns gang members so you know if
you're feeling you need protection
safety in numbers oh and they have
access to weapons
that's kind of a uh
a dangerous mix for the people who are
involved because it really does the the
truth is the more you're involved the
more likely you are to get harmed and
even though you need safety and that
fact that fact that people feel so
unsafe
they're willing to do things they know
will make them less safe
speaks to the just the level of need
there is to make people especially young
people feel safe in schools and their
community and their homes
and um and that's a tall order you know
that's a tall order that is not just one
system or one agency right it's a it's a
it's definitely a whole level thing and
so it's not just the essence of what is
going on with the gangs here it's not al
capone and you know a machine that is
like uh doing big high level crime or
anything like that it's more like a
local social
uh
you know us against the world kind of
thing i mean if i'm a kid growing up in
a certain block of chicago what you're
telling me is that
life is tough uh it's dangerous out
there and i'm gonna seek safety in the
gang that has been
either running i guess or at least uh
involved with my block for decades now
that's right and i just want to just
reiterate again you know
if there there are 900 crews in chicago
there are probably a handful that are
actively involved in some organized
stuff and every year every other year
you'll see a big federal case from the
u.s attorney's office
those four or five groups that are
involved in that should be treated you
know in that way figure out the
activities but that means you know
895 of them are not
and so the danger when it comes to
policy is that you treat those
895 or 885
as if they were
al capone yeah right or the gangster
disciples of the 90s or whatever the
case might be and they're just they're
just not and that is that's the slippery
slope with gang policies gangs become
you know a catch-all for everything bad
and evil and the boogeyman and in
reality most are as you described a crew
of people on the block who are
protecting themselves and their friends
and by the way you know sometimes
avenging them and that creates problems
that need resolution for sure
but um you know i think again i think
our us attorney's office in illinois
makes these big cases because they can't
because it's happening but we have to
remember that most groups are not that
uh most groups are these these sort of
side corner groups and and some of them
are a little bit bigger but they're
small
and they um they're they the history is
there and it's tied to a very specific
place that's been segregated and locked
up and locked out for generations other
than just sort of mutual protection or
even just socializing are the gangs also
involved in uh the drug trade or petty
crimes or protection rackets anything
like that i don't know what the life
side of the gang member is really like
to be honest i think so i think the um
the best way to describe you know
delinquent or criminal activity of gangs
is cafeteria style
so which is most groups do a little of
this a little of that we sell something
we steal something we're bored we're at
a party we have fight
most of it is not extremely well thought
out or planned quite the opposite most
of it's very haphazard
um you know violence is ever present in
their lives it occupies consumes
traumatizes and re-traumatizes
but they don't spend every in fact they
spend most of their
days in total compliance with the law
playing video games looking at social
media
you know hanging out like basically what
young people do
uh or or people in their 20s do
uh most of it is not spent you know
thinking about or even or engaging in in
crime but violence is ever present it
really does consume
uh the all of their energy and time but
it's not something they're engaging in
constantly if that were true the you
know the levels of violence would be
even worse than they are but it's not
it's sporadic it's rare but traumatic
and and lingers like a ghost
uh you know in in the on the block that
haunts them and re-haunts them i'm kind
of intrigued by the role of social media
here which i never really thought of
like are the are the gangs uh insulting
each other on twitter or how is this
working yeah
um so i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna have to to defer to some of my
great colleagues forrest stewart at
stanford desmond patton uh at columbia
and uh
jeffrey lane at rutgers you know it's
complicated so first of all
i don't know anybody between 14 and say
26 who's not on social media
so so it's important to distinguish this
is just normal behavior being on social
media connecting you know ribbing people
trolling people it's not necessarily
nice behavior trolling people but it's
just part of
i have teenagers myself right it's just
part of uh you know what we do as a
society
what what's happening on social media is
people are using it to
you know taunt rivals to disrespect
rivals to honor their friends uh as one
of as one of our colleagues desmond
patton talks about to express grief
deeply in ways that are hard to do in
other spaces um all of that's playing
out online
uh
the vast majority of these things that
happen online never never end up in
violence right they they are in fact
ways to do symbolic violence which is
not good either to be clear the problem
is of course when it does lead to
offline violence and we don't actually
know enough about it yet to understand
what it does it does seem in my
assessment it does seem to make things
ramp up much more quickly because it's
not nonstop right um and it can you know
especially where where music is
concerned drill music you can tell your
story or you can and it's out there and
now other people can view it so it's
almost public it's public displays
people are watching and seeing and
reacting which is nothing different than
what people do offline except it's
immediate and you have a broader
audience you can spread very um go viral
you can spread very quickly right but
again the link between online and
offline violence is is it's hard to make
it causal
but it definitely does happen and i
think people are working on it to try
and understand
you know how can that be used because i
will also tell you outreach workers in
the city
use it to to to calm things down as well
right so you can use those tools and
there are plenty of people talking about
well can we have trained social workers
in this space or people that can respond
and outreach workers and violence
prevention start doing that naturally
but again it's sort of part of
what you do you got somebody's name you
look them up you google them right so of
course it's going to permeate that part
of of work and culture as well part of
me wants to say that we should you know
try to replace actual
fights with guns on the streets with
fights in world of warcraft or something
like that but i but i figured probably
like you're implying maybe that if they
did that they would just spill over into
the streets anyway so maybe that's not
the right thing to do but well again i
think we just need to take stock of
where we are as a
society this is not new right we used to
the 1940s there were entire senatorial
hearings on mickey mouse and comic books
and mad magazine
um because it was a new form of media or
record hearings around you know ozzy
osbourne or nwa like this is a common
theme this is just the latest way of
things kind of getting out there but the
speed with which it happens is quite
different of course because it's
immediate and it it can kind of you know
does things don't get to calm down as
much and you mentioned a little bit but
i wanted to
focus in on just for a second the role
of the police in this um
it can be for better for worse i imagine
uh
do you think there's an issue where
police are just sort of ignoring certain
neighborhoods letting things go or is it
that there's a strategy that is just
ill-suited to the circumstances in in
these certain neighborhoods
well it's so yes and yes you know i
think um
[Music]
again it
the crime map in chicago about which
neighborhoods have the the highest
levels of violence hasn't changed in a
century so it's not a secret to anybody
how those places are policed
are of course severe right and in fact
it's changed in in this between the 60s
and the 80s the cry was there was no
police presence and now we're on the
other end of the spectrum where
everything is hyper surveilled yeah so i
think you know the idea of being
constantly surveilled and constantly
incarcerated or stopped
is still true i think it's just it's a
it is a
tragic way of life and it hasn't changed
and i think that's kind of what some of
the calls are there are things in in of
course policing that and again what we
know about policing that is associated
with gun violence reductions it's
actually
limited very small and very precise it's
not it's the opposite of stop and frisk
right so policing that is known to have
an impact on gun violence tends to focus
on a small number of people a small
number of places and a small number of
behaviors
which is an argument for more focused
rather than broadened policing powers
and policing activity
still a lot of problems which can cause
damage of course as well if you get the
wrong people or you're looking at the
wrong behaviors but by and large the
research suggests that focused policing
is much more impactful on levels of gun
violence than
than expansion of it
but they continually show up in the same
neighborhoods time and time and time
again so you know neighborhoods are
subjected to the same sorts of
surveillance and policing and it spills
over into schools and parks and
libraries and sort of other spaces as
well so i think this is where the
network analysis stuff that you
mentioned earlier begins to come in uh
there's a network of people let me just
ask the obvious question are we talking
about networks of
victims of shootings or networks of
people shooting other people
so great question so when i'm talking
the networks are created
through instances of co-arrest or being
stopped together
uh by the police so
it is actually setting aside anything
around culpability it's an observation
made by police at a point in time and
space um you know there are biases in
police data which are important we're
able to see a lot of those so say
failure to comply
often is something that's officer based
robbery assault arson things like that
tend to be come to the attention of
police from from civilians so we take
all those things to account but
basically if you and i rob somebody
together we have a tie and then if i
you know commit an assault with somebody
else we have a tie and you string these
things together and it creates actually
a network of of uh
risky behaviors right right things that
are inherently you and i engaging in a
behavior that that could be risky
so but to your comment about victim and
suspect or people that are involved um
i focus mainly on victims
one because in chicago we have abysmally
low clearance rates but more to the
point
violence prevention is about saving
lives
and focusing on who's in harm's way
who's experiencing trauma is the kind of
most immediately actionable information
and we generally have all of the
information about who was injured
and you know from a public health
standpoint it shouldn't matter whether
you have a felony conviction or
you know are a bad parent or you dropped
out of none of that should matter if
you're focusing on saving somebody's
life
so the focus tends to be on victims but
the victims and suspects and sort of
everybody else who's involved they're
all in the same network basically um and
so but but really valuing life
and prioritizing that is really key as
we think about how you use these things
for for intervention purposes but as far
as your data are concerned then uh if
there is someone who gets shot just as a
an accident or you know was an innocent
bystander during a robbery they would
still count as in your network because
you're not trying to you're not deciding
ahead of time that doesn't count
correct correct they're in there and by
the way you know what one of the things
we learned by having them in there
is many of these sort of stray bullet
incidents aren't aren't that far
straight
right they're tragic
um they weren't the intended target but
they were literally standing next to
somebody who was and so by the way this
often happens and you can change the
name of the individual i often do this
when i go to different cities i'll
describe a
seven-year-old who got
shot at a park or a birthday party and
their parent or their cousin was the
intended target and we hear about the
young seven-year-old but we don't hear
about the the
27 year old who was holding their hand
and so tragic but not random right well
i guess
that was gonna be my next question i
mean are there do we count also people
who are clearly related uh either
socially or or biologically to the
person in the network or you know an
associate of them or where
how much subjectivity versus objectivity
is involved in drawing the lines between
who's in a network and who's not
in in our particular case we still rely
on
a metric that we have for everybody
right so if we have the all of the say
arrests in chicago that's what includes
you in this in the sample which by the
way to your point means we're severely
underestimating relationships okay good
right so if you rob a bank with somebody
he's probably not a stranger it's
probably somebody you know
could be kin
could be a neighbor could be somebody a
classmate it's probably somebody you've
known a long time
but we don't have that information at a
minimum we have we were connected at
least once sometimes more than once
but we're probably underestimating
behavior and of course
most incidents never get reported to the
police um to begin with so you know
we're continuing so our estimates are
extremely conservative
if you have information like you're
talking about and we see this
qualitatively like when we're working
with partners
or we're trying to understand more about
a particular neighborhood or group or
whatever then we start to get into this
information and to your point yeah
somebody's you know former romantic
partner or their year neighbor of 20
years or their cousin or their uncle
but we just don't have that
systematically but you know
qualitatively it seems to be true but i
don't have it at the same level of
analysis as these other instances yeah
you kind of begin to see as a scientist
why the surveillance state is so
attractive because we'd have so much
more data if we just tracked everybody
and knew everything about them could
plug it into a computer i'm not actually
in favor of a very high level
surveillance date like that but the data
would be cleaner if we do everything
so nor my to be clear and also to be
clear we're using publicly available
arrest records so we're not using
cctv
license plates readers um you know all
those things are a totally different
level again going to we rely on
basically public data
you know you can go to your court and
get arrest records we're just looking at
the digital versions of those which
again in most cases are are available um
we don't even have to foia them but you
could um you know it's just a matter of
looking at them slightly differently
you know of course the the
surveillance
state in that way is is also goes
horribly wrong i know you were
teasing we're on tape here i want to
make sure
no
you have to uh what we're doing and what
we're not doing you're not allowed to
joke on the podcast without immediately
saying that was a joke otherwise people
will take it out of context it's
absolutely true but that does uh bring
up you know the prospect of perhaps
or maybe it's already happening
collaborating with either police
departments or public health uh agencies
or something like that i mean you say
that you just use publicly available
data but are there further prospective
investigations in the future where you
use other kind of data sets
so you named
two so short answer is there's lots of
potential uses for the science but you
name two agencies that use them very
differently you mentioned the police and
public health entities
there's a third one which i'm working
with which are community-based entities
police have used these technologies and
sort of approaches and it hasn't gone
extremely well
and it hasn't gone extremely well
because they've done typically what
police do they they get some print out
they make a list and they do what cops
do which is they work a list and
whoever's on the top of the list is
number one and who's ever number two is
number two
and you know
that's that's how policing tends to work
they work calls they work lists um which
is problematic when it's something
that's imperfect like data and an
analytics right
when you look at the predictions or when
you look at these statistical models
they're they're pretty good they help
they give you information but if you
find if you follow them blindly it's
problematic it's especially problematic
when it's done from the arm of the state
that treats a victim like an offender
right sure so as soon as you start
going into this world of trying to find
a suspect or trying to find a quote
fender
there's this little thing called the
constitution and even you know bigger
thing called morality about what how do
you do that in a way that's fair and
just and transparent and we haven't seen
that done successfully yet
in the policing context
in a public health context
the science is exactly the science of
contact tracing it's it's literally
finding out who's in harm's way
getting resources to keep them safe
and it can be done successfully and
we've seen this done by the way in other
epidemics the hiv epidemic when we have
outbreaks of other infectious diseases
you know covid is in one example but
kovitz spreads
much more quickly than gun violence it's
an air it's an airborne pathogen right
um and so it's harder to contain covet
gun violence is relational so it does
not it's more like a blood-borne
pathogen than an airborne pathogen
but you're still tracing these patterns
this is what street outreach workers do
which is the last thing i'll mention
where we're trying to find the uses
street outreach workers
these these you know people with lived
experience that are trying to stop
disputes they literally place themselves
in these networks
um that's how they do their job they're
trying to figure out what are the active
disputes
how do i get myself situated in there
such that
we we reduce harm that's a perfect use
for it that's not tied to overly harsh
penalties or removing somebody's
liberties also not without potential
problems but you know there are ways
we've done this again in public health
um that i think offer at least a
starting point to use it
the last thing i'll say this comparison
is when you think about science
right
science is providing some tools how do
we use that tool
so when you think about
spatial uh models well it can it can
help get a fire truck to the scene of a
fire more quickly or it can be used to
direct a drone same math
but the use is fundamentally different
and we need to be honest about how it's
being used
as an academic i try to say here's what
i think i try to work with partners to
make sure that happens um but you know
science gets out there in peer-reviewed
journals and anybody can pick it up and
yeah and take and go with it i'm trying
to figure out ways to to improve that
approach but
um you know it's it's uh it's tricky
well i love the fact that you bring up
the idea that the cops just tend to have
a list and work the list and you're what
you're doing is something a bit more
sophisticated than that because you have
more information than just an unordered
list and this is where it becomes a
little mathy a little sciency in a fun
way when you have these networks so you
have nodes who are people and they're
connected by relationships
as far as i know i'm not a super expert
but there are different kinds of
networks right there are dense networks
sparse networks small world networks uh
are there characteristic features of the
kinds of networks that you're seeing
so this is a great this is a great
question let me also just say
when you talk about we all live in these
worlds right and we all know a lot about
our own small world
and so when you bring these images say
to street outreach workers or teachers
my sister's a teacher we often talk
about like what i was like tell me
what's going on in your school she
starts describing him i see network
images
right
so if you have that
image if you have the roadmap the whole
roadmap
and you have experts that can be like
let me tell you about this network i can
only say you and i
you know rob somebody together but then
someone's like no let me tell you sean
and andy played football together and
john used to date andy's sister and then
they broke up and then he hung out all
of a sudden
the context becomes important and you
only get that by engaging local experts
good preachers teachers cops outreach
workers social workers they know a
community or they should know a
community
that's what makes this information
actionable and that's what didn't happen
in some of these instances like if
you're just working a list you don't
care whether sean's already got a job
and turned his life around he's on the
list right right
what what similarities are we seeing in
these networks what are we seeing to
answer your other question
one they're super small and they're
super concentrated so even when you
think of a neighborhood that's
disproportionately impacted by gun
violence
with say
40 000 people this network has a couple
hundred people in it it's very small
it's also not secret that's the other
thing if you actually talk to folks
they'll be like oh there's a crew over
here well who's in the like they can
tell you these things so it's it it
requires again being really connected to
community approaches or the community
itself
to make it actionable so it clusters
it's very small
and that's this is true in in most
communities in most cities regardless of
city size regardless of the size of the
neighborhood it's a very small part of
any community that is actively engaged
in these things
and then of course this the other kind
of thing we're seeing which is more the
rule than the exception is
gunshot victimizations
cluster they clump together so even
within this space this social space
there's still a pocket
where these were these shootings cluster
which again when you think about the
implications for immediate intervention
setting aside large-scale interventions
that are needed to keep people out of
these networks in the first place
it means you're talking about focused
interventions
right that can reach people as opposed
to broad scale
you know
stop and frisk right
it's the opposite of that it's it's it's
when it's kind of focusing on particular
behaviors particular individuals
particular geographic locations and
that's where the attention is and you
can do that with
therapy you can do that with
interventions you can do that with jobs
you can do that with schools but you
also have to know what are those what do
those individuals in that network need
do they already have high school
diplomas do they already have jobs maybe
they don't need a job because they
already have one spoiler alert they need
jobs
right
but like if i already have a job the job
program is not appealing if i already
have a high school diploma i don't need
a ged program
we are smart enough as humans to be able
to to figure out
what individuals who are in say a small
network me you ask them actually
right or you ask people who know them
hey there are these 20 folks you know on
in in your in your neighborhood what do
you know them what do they need and then
you can kind of direct accordingly it
can't just be everybody needs to do
these three things go
it has to be like what are we what are
we learning about the problem it might
not involve groups or gangs it might be
a family dispute it might be intimate
partner violence it's important to know
that
and every neighborhood's a little
different you know in chicago latino
communities have a very different sort
of gang presence still than black
communities right they're just they're
different groups
you can't do you can't cut and paste you
got to understand the contexts you know
conversely black communities don't have
to fear ice the way latino communities
did especially under trump right there
was a clear
you know fear that rose during that
during those four years that changed the
dynamic of people talking to people
and you know
you wouldn't expect that say in a black
community in chicago well i'm not sure
how uh helpful it is to your research
but just i do have to ask about the
topology of these networks are they
situations where there's like a
set a very very very small set of super
influencers who know everybody or is it
that everybody else in the network knows
everybody else i mean that would
presumably suggest different strategies
for dealing with things
so there are different topologies the
the general rule is in networks but we
also see this in where violence is
concerned
most people have one or two ties right
most people
most humans right we're talking about
people right they age out of crime
you know when you think about young men
in particular
young men in particular do a lot of
risky
stupid things until they're 26 27 years
old this is true of
of humanity
and so
that's what we see most people have one
or two ties and then there are some
people that have a lot of ties
right and the people that have a lot of
ties
are hubs
they are you use the word influencer we
could think about super spreaders right
yeah
this idea that they are
people who navigate
different sorts of networks and bring
stuff with them and
you know part of what we're seeing is
that those folks are especially
vulnerable
because they are
you know if you're again let's just use
the context of street crews right or
gangs
if you hang around with one gang we know
it increases your rate of victimization
but if you're starting to hang around
with two or three or four different
crews and those crews don't like each
other
either you have some some kind of
predisposition to make everybody like
you or you're really putting yourself
out there yeah and you could be putting
it out there for all sorts of reasons
family ties back in countries you know
it could be it could be an inadvertent
ties about schools or sports or you
could be running a
a scam or an operation or you could
actually be engaging in dealing firearms
or drug whatever i don't know
but that person who is connecting
disconnected parts of the networks
they're
they're they're unique and there aren't
as many of them most folks have one or
two ties and it's not even it's not a i
say a big deal it is a big deal because
it puts them in harm's way but it's not
for stuff
these these we're not talking about
kingpins right yeah most most of the
people that are caught up in these
spaces are
just
regular folks i mean i guess that's
that's the point the short uh
lesson here is that it's not really
a dictatorship with one person ruling
everything and telling everyone what to
do it's a it sounds like it's a little
bit more organic with people knowing
each other and knowing each other
yeah that's right i think let me just
just to say one important caveat there's
and let's put this in scale right now
it's hard to estimate there are about
900 crews gangs in chicago
the way vast majority of them are are
these neighborhood based small entities
which is a departure from chicago in the
90s of course
but most of them are the side street
street crews
20 guys very informal structures
there are absolutely one or two or three
maybe even 10 groups that are more
organized and really kind of you know
involved in deep deeper criminal
activities
on those 10 though turns out
law enforcement knows how to make cases
on those times they've been doing it for
years
the mistake is when you treat those
other 890 like those 10
right
and which which is those other 890 which
is the majority of the of the the sort
of groups they're just different you
know they are
it's it's not an on off switch it's a
toggle switch right you know we have
this crew it's from the block there's
some family ties in it you know
somebody gets hurt we rally together and
things get amped up and then it kind of
just calms down and then i get a job and
i leave or i have a kid and i stop
hanging out like it's much more
amorphous than that which makes it a
little scarier
in some ways because you don't have
these nice neat categories like gang a
gang b gang c gang d it's messy
um
unlike chicago in the 90s people liked
it there was this nation there was that
nation we didn't get along i could draw
a schematic everybody understood it it's
not like that anymore and it's not like
that in most cities in the u.s
and so what yeah i mean part of your
ambition obviously is just as an
academic you want to understand what's
going on but you also want to do some
good here because it does seem like
there's room for doing some good and the
good to be done is not just help to
arrest people who shoot others but to
prevent it from happening ahead of time
right to give some warning i mean can
you say a little bit about
how we would imagine very very in a very
specific way what we would do
to lower the chances that someone is
going to be uh a victim of one of these
shootings
yeah so i think the first thing if we
take the lessons we've learned and again
i want to stress that this is more of
the
triage approach
but you do need to combine it with with
thinking about these bigger issues like
keeping people out of these networks in
the first place
when there's an event when there's a
shooting
saturating that part of the network
with a trauma response
could be could be life-saving which is
you can help mitigate retaliation which
happens in about a thirty cases in
chicago
but more than that if you reduce the
trauma of the people involved you are
saving lives right
so
what and we're starting to see this in
hospital-based programs as well right
they're starting treating the victim's
trauma immediately and the victim's
family's trauma immediately by trying to
connect them with services by trying to
you know divert aggression by trying to
really understand and unpack
the health consequences of individuals
that are involved i think that's one of
the most promising things but we're
still learning a lot about that so one
of the differences
in
our prior research on say ptsd
a lot of which say comes from
a veterans
you know veterans have in theory
left the war zone as it were right
they're now home and so how do you
reintegrate
a vet into their home life which is in
theory safe yeah a lot of the young
people who are caught up in shootings
they go right back to the same block
they were shot 600 feet away from their
home and they walk past that every day
right and so they're re-traumatized
simply by living in the same
neighborhood and they see the people
that shot him
so it's different it's new and and
understanding that element
that you have to deal with the trauma
and people that are continually
re-exposed to it and then somebody else
gets shot
right
on the same block that that's unique and
we we need to we need to really
you know triple down on that and invest
in it and understand that it is it is
different than other contexts and you
know and it's also thinking about it's
not like the public health system has a
glowing report card from black and and
other non-white communities in this
country you know there's cynicism
there's estrangement there's there's all
of these things that have been done you
know tuskegee experiments and beyond
uh that
that we need to understand in this
context so you know but i do think
responding to precise parts of a network
quickly can can reduce some of the
trauma it won't eliminate it you know i
think it's it's
when we get into this world and we use
words like prediction
you know chasing that as the answer is
is is not the solution understanding
it's more information
okay that you can respond to quickly
that's kind of the the key in my opinion
but let me just let me just figuring out
how to respond quickly yeah let me just
try to distinguish between uh what seems
natural and obvious to me which is that
literally the family members that go to
the hospital with the shooting victim uh
deserve some
uh care and and uh
attention to to help them get over this
trauma but then
are are you suggesting that there are
people that you can identify as being in
the network with that victim even though
they don't go to the hospital even
though they weren't there but is there a
broader strategy just to warn people or
or help them
lower their chances of being part of
this cycle of violence
well that's a good question i think
for folks that have been in and you know
shout out to other first responders in
this space
when you're in a hospital room after a
shooting
it is a microcosm of the neighborhood
and the dispute in many cases so
not only of the victim and their family
or somebody showing up there so are the
police
uh oftentimes other people are injured
as well
and so you have in in a
matter of minutes or hours you have the
victim the victim's family the police
the health care system
potentially child and protective
services you know who's in like
everybody is converging
uh and this time and pace while
somebody's going through the worst
moment of their life
and so it is an opportunity to see
and be first-hand proximate to those
folks that you might not have
information on and reach them and by the
way when i talk about family i don't you
know just going back to the parts of our
conversation the average age of a
homicide victim in chicago is
uh 27 and a half years old it's almost
28 years old
when we look at some of the programs who
are serving this population
a good chunk of those 27 and 28 year
olds have kids
so you now have a child whose parent has
been shot potentially murdered might be
incarcerated
and we talk about a cycle of violence
that's an instance where the cycle of
violence
is is occurring right a child
experiencing this trauma
now having to have a parent who's dead
incarcerated or or injured
that kid needs some attention too
right right getting that and when we
work with outreach organizations and and
are dealing with folks that are injured
and have survived
i can't tell you the number of times
people said i wish this was there when i
was 12 or i was in middle school or what
about my little cousin or what about my
kid
that had access to these things so
thinking about those moments when you
can make those connections
to non-punitive ways to to improve
people's lives i think those are
opportunities to be clear i think this
space isn't is people are innovating
right now because we haven't done this
and especially as we're in a time when
there's an increase in gun violence
nation you know nationwide
the the i the potential for innovation
is huge
but it means we got to listen to folks
that are doing the work that's right and
just listen to doctors first responders
community violence preventionists um
educators social workers there's lots of
folks that know a lot about this that
are there how do we boost the things we
think are helpful and how do we turn
down the things we think you know are
potentially harmful which makes me
wonder i mean
coming the other way do you find that
those people who you just listed as well
as the law enforcement side of things do
they listen to you as the uh ivory tower
academic from evanston coming in and
saying you know you really need some
more network theory in your life
well you know uh yeah of course they
listen to me no i like to think they
listen to me i should be more
precise and say i get invited to
to these spaces and to be clear i'm
honored to be in those spaces because
i'm also invited into again from
neighborhood organizations to the state
houses and
it's i'm glad that i'm in those spaces
and i appreciate being in those spaces
i think um
they listen
understanding that some of these things
don't work on an election cycle is
tricky or a funding cycle is tricky but
i think people inherently understand the
importance of under you know context and
networks
i think we air in the policy realm
towards individual explanations right
and as as a sociologist as a social
scientist you know crime rates are way
more than people making bad decisions
that's an overly simplistic
view of of crime and violence right
but you mean you laugh
that's how a lot of our programming and
responses are trying to get people to
make better decisions now let's be clear
plenty of people make bad decisions
right i'm not saying people don't have
choices and everything is forced people
make choices
choices are tough so if you feel unsafe
if you feel your life is in danger
to you carrying a gun even if you're
prohibited because the state is not
there for you is a reasonable choice
but then it comes back to why are there
so many guns in my neighborhood why is
the state failing to protect me and why
am i in harm's way to begin with all of
those things
they have nothing to do with your choice
they have everything to do with the
context in which you live
and and that part is harder to kind of
think about in just an individual
response and and going back to something
we said earlier
you know
if you follow the program
and you have a hundred percent
attendance
and you get shot
does the program fail
um because your your opposition didn't
change their behavior even if you as an
individual changed your behavior it gets
really really complicated really fast
even when you see approaches that are
trying to to focus on individuals and
change behaviors and which is important
again you don't want people carrying
guns you want people to make better
decisions you want them to be you know
get complete education and so on you can
have individuals who complete the
programs who have 100 attendance who
stop carrying guns but the neighborhood
hasn't changed and so they're victimized
not because they're still involved but
because the opposition is still involved
right
and so if you're not paying attention to
the context all of a sudden what looks
like an individual failure you know
isn't right um
and it's tricky because again you want
to reach people and have services but
understanding context be some so key and
thinking about
neighborhood level interventions right
how do you understand the dynamics in
the whole neighborhood how do you
understand all these other reasons we
can't keep our eye off of that so we
can't just you know we have to move
beyond purely individual
uh
solutions though we need plenty of
individual solutions as well we need
everything but um i do like to just
caution that you know how we understand
patterns
is is much more than just individuals
going back to networks networks aren't
about one person
they're about a system
right it's a systems approach to
understanding these things and that
involves understanding dynamics and time
and context and
all the other things that are involved
you know it and then you can kind of
zoom in and out when you need an
individual approach it's an individual
approach when you need something larger
it should be something larger and do it
all at once p.s so well you've certainly
given us a lot to think about let me
just uh maybe for a final thought ask
whether or not
this kind of way of thinking about
things extends to the other kinds of gun
violence that we opened the podcast
talking about about suicides mass
shootings uh you've been talking
focusing on a specific way that gun
violence happens are there broader
lessons to be drawn for this
way higher than it should be number of
shootings that we have in our country
it's hard because i don't study
um
[Music]
you know
i don't study suicide but because
suicide seems
isolated it's actually almost the
inverse so when we think about
what we know about suicide attempts say
among high school age students
we actually know that those that have
sparse networks or no networks have more
suicide attempts
okay slightly different though than than
the types of networks that we're talking
about so there's potentially some
relationships but i don't think it's the
same pattern just given the isolations
it's really hard to understand mass
shootings in this context only because
again in most cases the target
has some
network related purpose right
my former school my current school a
lover uh a workplace that i was involved
in so there's non-random connection in
some instances
um but it's not
it's it's not quite as clustered as you
might think again thinking about warning
signs red flags
even in the domestic violence situations
intimate partner violence red flags kind
of tell you still not random
still a network we have an intimate
relationship but slightly different and
i don't know enough about it to say it
you know i think um
i think that becomes i think that
becomes
kind of important as usual this is a
perfect place to end in the sense that
uh you just said you don't know enough
which is good i i like it when people
say they don't know enough about
something not everyone is willing to do
that and occasionally it's exactly the
right thing to say so andrew papa
christos thanks very much for being on
the windscape podcast it was a pleasure
i really appreciate it and happy happy
to follow up on anything
[Music]
you